[Applause]
[Music]
in 1991 after several years of
negotiations and a whole lot of tension
the Baltic states Lithuania Latvia and
this dunya finally managed to break away
from the Soviet Union they finally had
the freedom that they'd wanted for so
long
[Music]
since then fifty years have passed since
the soldiers of the Red Army occupied
these countries but during the years
under the Soviets repression and fear
were the basic ingredients in the lives
of the people in Estonia Latvia and
Lithuania let's now have a look at some
pretty alarming data in Lithuania alone
in a country of little more than 2.5
million people these numbers were
recorded 200,000 people were arrested
questioned and prisoned 132 thousand
people were deported
especially to Siberia only five thousand
prisoners deportees and partisans were
eliminated by the Soviet regime and if
all of that wasn't enough but the time
of their independence poverty and
shortages were everyday realities for
all of the inhabitants of these country
I remember the days when the counters of
the shops and to Lynn were empty and the
people were starving economy more or
less had to be rebuilt from scratch
since then the view of things have
changed a lot there more than a lot in
fact from the very moment these
countries regained their independence
they decided to bet it all on democracy
and freedom
[Music]
their economies are today some of these
freest ones they are members of the EU
and NATO and they prosper today these
are countries with very high standards
of living and they can really be
considered rich countries the
transformation it really has been total
and remarkable in 2009 they suffered
along with the rest of the world through
these financial crisis and it really
seemed as if their economies were on the
verge of collapse
last year's economy contracts almost 18
percent in the fourth quarter of 2009
but against all odds they managed to
recover in a very short period of time
indeed they became an example to other
countries like Spain Greece and Portugal
but that's a whole different thing that
we're going to talk about in the future
video in this video we're going to focus
on Lithuania and talk about a problem
that is shared by a lot of the countries
in Eastern Europe a problem that today
is actually one of the biggest threats
to their future
[Music]
brain drain
the history of litter a Nia and all of
the Baltic states in general since their
freedom in 1991 well it's a history of
success today they are modern modes and
countries with prosperous economies but
as with any good story not everything is
quite so pretty yes there are issues
these countries are facing and today
we're going to particularly focus on
Lithuania in this country the biggest
problem is brain drain
yep that's emigration with an E and this
is no small problem for the country
since 2004 when the country was
integrated into the EU but away Nia has
lost more than 10% of its population
that is more than 300,000 people
especially young people have decided to
pack up and move to a different country
most of those have chosen to move to the
United Kingdom yeah while in Western
Europe and the United States they are
concerned about immigration in
miscellanea it is the other way around
they are concerned about people leaving
they are worried that this might end up
D capitalizing the country since 1990 we
have lost about 800,000 people and for a
small country this is a huge loss we are
losing our youngest and brightest and in
the future we will just have old people
who will be dying we will have a dying
Society and as always the ones who are
leaving tend to be the most capable and
the best prepared young people this of
course has a significant impact on the
country's economy the number of young
people working decreases talent leaves
the country and the population ages but
this is not just a problem for Lithuania
[Music]
there's the early 1990s some 20 million
of Central and Eastern Europe's most
talented workers have left and they have
headed largely to Western Europe so who
do you think has benefited from all of
this talent redistribution yeah you got
that right it's the wealthiest countries
and that is why we have to be careful
about the messages being sent by
politicians who are attempting to
criminalize immigration in order to get
votes yes we're looking at you to reason
a and Donald Trump thought I mean I know
you're thinking if the Baltic countries
have been so successful why are people
leaving well because they are looking
out for their own personal success look
for one these countries have managed to
develop a well-prepared young population
who can also speak English to must have
as when it comes to looking for a future
in another place and then we also have
the fact that because of all the growths
that have happened since 1991 these
people it can now leave the country in a
comfortable way but there is still the
key question to answer why are they
leaving if things are going so well well
that's not really that hard to explain
even though salaries have improved a lot
in the last several years the difference
between the wealthiest countries is
still quite big at an example while the
average salary in Lithuania is about 800
euros in the United Kingdom it is almost
two thousand five hundred euros or three
times more all of this what I might
leave you wondering whether this
impressive economic development was
actually good for the Baltic countries
well we would say that overall yes it's
certainly worth it but it does leave us
with a couple of very important
questions well the first one is what is
the cost of all of this and second how
can they stop the brain drain putting an
end to emigration so stopping this brain
drain it's become a pretty major
priority for Eastern European countries
in some of these countries like Poland
Latvia and Hungary they have started a
return campaign in order to persuade
emigrants to come back home I would
welcome all Polish people who went
abroad if only they could come back it
would be a great day for Poland however
while this is it's a nice sentiment it
is definitely in this urania where there
is a larger concern about the brain
drain that there has been more
significant support from society the
last parliamentary elections celebrated
in October the Lithuanian greens and
farmers union won the elections and took
control of the government this pinterest
party had only one MP in the previous
elections their main promise putting an
end to emigration well of course this is
easier said than done so the question is
how is this party going to succeed party
led by the way--by rameneh's cabacas´s
one of the most important businessman in
the country
well apparently their top priority is to
stop emigration by attracting much more
foreign investment they claim that if
they can succeed in getting more foreign
money for investments they will be able
to provide more jobs with higher
salaries so well how are they planning
to do this well by reducing bureaucracy
chasing corruption and also by making
adjustments to the labor market and the
truth is that this does make a ton of
sense and we
say that the Baltic countries really do
seem to know how to get things done but
all don't for just a second because this
it's not the end of the story there are
some other things that well they don't
look quite so good the shadows of the
Lithuanian plan on the one hand at the
same time as the government promised
foreign investments they have also
committed to raise taxes by eliminating
what is known as a flat tax in Lithuania
as well as in Estonia and Latvia the tax
systems they're really simple in
Lithuania's case there is this flat tax
which is a rate of 15% for people and
companies that is to say the Delicia
rhenium who makes $10,000 pays one
thousand five hundred dollars in taxes
and the one who makes ten times more at
a hundred thousand euros also pays ten
times more at fifteen thousand euros
raising taxes in this way sort of goes
against the foreign investments in
higher salaries plan and this rise will
directly harm both of those things
and by the way corporate taxes they're
not as low as they might seem if we add
up the social security contributions and
other taxes companies pay more than 40%
of their gross profits and taxes
according to the World Bank and now we
also have to point out the issue of
russia-nato the previous Lithuanian
governments and the current is no
exception have insisted on scaring the
population and also the rest of the
world with the Russian threat saying
that the country is constantly in danger
okay now while it is true that these
threats are real it's not really a
brilliant way to instill confidence in
potential investors and finally and
maybe most importantly of all there is a
cultural matter that affects the entire
country so you might wonder right if
there's this brain drain going on
wouldn't it be logical to try and
compensate for this by bringing in young
professionals from other countries well
that's kind of a problem because this
country it's also a bit suspicious about
immigration most of these countries
they're a touch nationalist anyway if
anything is for certain is that list
Urania is rather dystonia and latvia
have done their homework and their
policies are certainly much more
efficient than the ones that predominate
in the rest of europe remember in just
25 years they have managed to
comment rich countries with high
standards of living and well now would
like to know what you think do you think
these countries will finally be able to
stop this brain drain well we're looking
forward to hearing what you think in the
comments section below and as always if
you like this video please do hit that
like button and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday and don't forget to check out
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
aren't mine and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]